please help me welcome to the stage
Andrew Lincoln Danai gurira Chandler
Riggs Steve Young Horan cohan Ross
Marquand
Sonique WA Martin green Michael Cudlitz
Christian Serratos Josh McDermitt Norman
Reedus
and last but not least Jeffrey Dean
Morgan are we pissing off pants yet
you [ __ ]
you can breathe you can blink you can
[ __ ] cry I would oh he'll you're all
gonna be doing that or you can lead us
on a little moderation all right I
listen if it was me who got it in the
end I think people will be fine with
that this has been an amazing I will say
one thing about this happened over the
summer that I've not seen happen after
previous seasons which is this in this
incredible sense of community around
that even in the last panel some guy
said Houdini can kill I was in a remote
part of California and this old this guy
a barber outside his shop this old guy
was walking across the street never
would have thought to say hi to the guy
and he shouted across the street
I think it's gland or whatever and it's
just like this is that we're all
everyone's speculating and people are
asking huh what uh what's it been like
for you to be a become a part of this
fandom and to become a part of this
community I think I've been kind of
living in this bubble in Georgia I mean
I've only been on the show for about 12
minutes thus far um and then kind of
went to work but I've never I was in New
York when the first episode that you'll
see me aired in 16 I guess last year uh
and I've never been stopped so much in
my life ever and I'm getting a little
bit of a feel for it though we haven't
started airing yet I hang out with the
cast as the cast that shall not be named
yeah just the cast and people wherever
you are and we're kind of in the middle
of nowhere in Georgia but you can go
somewhere and people like come out of
the floor and ceilings and walls that
you didn't know we're there you think
you're kind of alone and and converge
upon the
it's amazing it's amazing and the fans
have been nothing but awesome as well as
everyone you see sitting up here well
this I mean I really you know to see
what's happened with walking dead and
having been there almost from the
beginning it's been an incredible thing
to watch and one of the most significant
experiences to be even close to but you
are now forever you are part of this
community in your part of this world
it's cool because I've been a fan of the
shows it started as well as the comic
book so then to step in in this role in
particular and with these people has
been nothing short of awesome
Scott can you talk a little about the
new locations and some of the new
characters and some of the stuff that
we're going to see in season seven
well there's Karen but you guys know a
lot about them you saw King Ezekiel
there yeah yeah there is there is that
is Carrie Peyton who is a remarkable
actor and I you know he's a bit younger
than is he he'll is in the book he's a
bit more svelte but he came in and he
owned it and the most important thing is
when I showed his audition to Robert
Robert went bananas he's fantastic I
think people are going to love them
excellent let's start talking to the
castle start with mr. Andrew Lincoln
this entire this entire the last half of
the season every episode as an audience
member I'm going oh man don't go in and
kill all this all you know it's just
like there was so much hubris and so
much like oh we we rule everything we
can take care of everything so can you
describe a little bit what it was like
shooting the final scene of last last
season well it sucked obviously and uh
you know the funny thing was my mom
who's become a really kind of weirdly
superfan she's always on the internet
checking out the show and she just I had
dinner before I came out and she said
you know you've got to get back to that
space you were at at the end of last
year and I said well what do you mean is
that well you've got to dig deep
seriously committed
and your face man you were terrified you
were weeping you were like a child you
were David and I said are you giving me
acting notes and even my wife just went
really come on Laura pipe down you know
but yeah so it was it was a pretty
intense return you know after having a
hiatus and sort of chilling in my
orchard to come back and see his face
it could I just point out that he's
having way too much fun playing this
dude and but look I'm not gonna talk
about it I I'm we made it I spoke about
this before and I'll say it again is
that we all linked arms it's it's a
really shitty start to the season but
hang in there guys I know you will
because we're we're heading towards I
think one of the greatest show downs
that we've had in this show since
terminus so hang in there with us I know
you will Steve Young who I know read the
comics before you've been a fan of
comics for the show and we we talked a
lot about when issue 100 came out and we
talked about this point of the story and
now here we are at this point in the
story so how has this felt for you and
what did it what did it feel like
reaching this part I've always been a
huge fan of the comics and I remember
that particular issue my cousin called
me and he was like yo Glen's got it too
good right now hundreds coming out I
don't know what's gonna happen and
obviously after 100 came out I was like
oh crap
it was it was a no crap but it was also
this amazing like this is incredible to
be a hundred issues in and to land a
bomb like this to propel it forward was
so incredible and for me as a fan I was
like this moment is iconic and however
it happens it's it's such a great moment
and when we let up to it to see you know
all the components that were happening
and to see negan in the flesh
it is awesome to know that from here on
out that there's going to be
an opening to just thrust the show even
further and for me as a fan and as a
participant like it's it's probably one
of the coolest things ever lauren cohan
you Maggie is Maggie's having a severe
medical crisis when we left off and on
top of the fact that she's kneeling in
front of negan and is probably as
conscious as she can be at this point
knows something really terrible is going
to happen so what what is the
preparation like with with that kind of
that layered tragedy yeah you know
what's funny this show gives us this
opportunity to go to such visceral
places and this episode that episode for
all of us was one of the most physically
and emotionally demanding things I mean
I was actually reflecting on it just
thinking I love Ross and Sonique WA and
Michael for carrying me on that stretch
of the day Sunday
and um it's it was you know we we had a
really good time and Andy and it was
when you see that purple exhausted
makeup and you I don't know for two
weeks or so we were sort of in that
state and it was just a really really
crazy thing I just I'm just like sitting
up here with everybody just thinking how
lucky we are to be you know you don't
act anything you get to go to the
creative space and obviously I'm don't
have the illness maggie has in there but
we we get to be together and like go to
physical crazy and emotionally crazy
places and we do that together
I don't know I'm on a bit of an
emotional tangent here but you get me
yeah yeah you don't you don't have that
illness though I don't I I did think
about when I had my appendix taken out
though and I had two days where my mom
was like you're fine you need to go to
the bathroom you're fine fine and then I
got to the hospital and they were like
wow you were about to die in here so
they took out my appendix so I channeled
a little bit of that but I mostly just
um you know that I think that episode
what's
so many of us have experiences that
guilt like is is the choice that that
character made responsible for getting
us to that to the end of negan's bat or
to the situation and Maggie definitely
you know was so you know feeling the
need to protect Chandler this scene for
you at the end I mean he's Carl's really
trying to grow up he's had to grow up
really fast and now he is Shawn's one
eye and so yours you're kneeling and you
have this patch on your eye so what how
is that as a performer like to to be
acting basically with a patch and what
was the experience like I mean death
perception is my my biggest loss there
it's so annoying cause like there's like
a bug I can't tell if it's like right
here or like right you'll just be like
swatting and bug like all the way over
there but I was just sure natural tick
no no crazy but um I don't know I mean
it's I actually um enjoyed wearing the
prosthetic in episode 9 a lot more than
I enjoy wearing the bandage just because
the bandage they always want like they
always want to see my eyebrows they have
to constantly push it up and then like
pull it down on this side and after
every take we have to readjust it versus
the prosthetic it's just like now we're
putting on and it looks really cool too
so it's it's a lot lot more chill and
easy but um yeah you don't realize how
much like vision you lose like it's like
a good 70 degrees of vision that is like
completely gone like remember Norman
tapping almost like constantly tapping
all my other shoulder and I'd be like
see uh deny I'd love to talk about
really quickly
you're Michonne has had such an
incredible she was this reclusive
warrior when we first saw her she was
very closed off then she started to open
up she was kind of reborn and now we're
actually seeing the most human complex
and romantic side of her so can you talk
a little bit about the vulnerability
between Rick and Michonne I
it was interesting because I was you
know I was thinking about this question
and I was the moment I feel where her
vulnerability really started to open up
specifically towards Rick actually I
think was a really long time ago it was
episode the episode entitled clear which
was also written by mr. Scott Gimple
over there and it really was this moment
I think where she not only bonds with
his son in a way that is really reviving
for her and opens her up and allows her
to start putting down all those layers
and all that all that armor just begin
to go there in terms of you know
investing in a young life and seeing his
light and and having an empathy sympathy
for this young man in this world and
knowing what it is like to be a mother
and wanting to be there for him and so
and his acceptance of her by the end of
the episode is really opens up her heart
but everything I think connected to Rick
and Michonne connects in with Carl too
at times because it's kind of like he
accepts her first and then there's the
moments between Rick and Michonne in
that episode that to me there's one in
particular that for me that day that we
shot it I was like huh means he's gonna
see him that way one day which was the
moment in uh it was in the jail cell
when we were looking for bullets and
ammo and there's none it was an ill
devised plan and Michonne does not call
him out for this but he kind of thinks
she is so she hands him the one bullet
that she did find and and he kind of
snaps it her and her responses you know
I don't have a problem with that and it
was so funny when we shot it it was the
crew there's the crew that were on set
they all looked over to mr. Gimbel
funnily cuz he was there of course and
they were like I reckon I get together
and I was like I was like huh and I
don't know I don't know what it was but
that moment I thought that makes sense
actually because this for her it made
sense to me because she is a woman who
has to deeply respect the man she opens
up to and that she was already
developing such a respect from him the
way she treated him verse
the way she treated the governor she
could see he was such a like he was a
good man
burdened with leadership versus he
needed leadership to feel like a man so
there was something about that connect
that realization seeing him like that
and seeing his brokenness and his pain
and things that she could connect to
that we're making her put down her mess
and and open up more so that sort of
journey if you know did I think it's
awesome it took as long as it did
because it developed a very complex
connection and allowed her to work
through her several wounds and an armory
well obviously Rick's other significant
romantic relationship is Darrell uh and
Norman I believe you brought a video to
illustrate this I'm terrified of what's
about to happen I'm like I'm on pins and
needles um yeah
this would happen duh for it started off
we went to Tokyo and uh we were super
tired and we were jet-lagged and we're
sitting there and and early in the
morning and Andy goes you speak a little
Japanese don't you know yeah and he goes
how do you say thank you for having me
in your country I didn't do the hand
movements yeah I did and so I said
toilet Waldo cold Eska and he goes how I
got toilet wha
doko duska then he goes wait wait before
we start toilet wha doko desu ka' and I
didn't do they're looking at him like
what and then he goes TOI they wha doko
dusk and he goes what did I just say and
I said where's the toilet
but there's a there's an ongoing prank
thing which I think something's about to
fall out of the sky yeah but um and then
I put chickens in his trailer one day
and then I came back from having my
windows tinted on my truck and it's in
it said Andy's bi TCH across the front
that was a really good one yeah very
much and then we had Transpo for that
help yeah and then we had then then I'm
on set and I get a package and I open it
and glitter explodes in my face knows
him yeah and then what happened next the
worst thing about that is that
that is such a mean prank that stuff
that is like glitters like clown herpes
like it does not know it doesn't come
out it never goes away absolutely right
I do in a year I'd be like it's still my
eye I drove home from that point and
there were people at red lights looking
at me like I was you know I could been
clubbing okay to a club you know what
I'm saying and then I went it I thought
I'm gonna have to before I go home and
get him humiliated I kind of went and
vacuumed the thing up you know and it
took me 25 minutes and I was beating up
with sweat and all the rest I got back
in the car and I cranked up the air
coming again and it just went dark in my
sweaty face and then I went to the
coffee shop and they said you've got
something in your hairline now they're
calling me sparkles glitter boy I used
to be somebody in my own hometown and
and and when I got on the plane to go to
San Diego my two children had tears in
their eyes and they said what didn't any
Norman do and I said sweethearts he's
humiliated your father in the national
scale and they said what can we do
unless so believe me with oh dear it's
in your beard yeah oh that could not
have backfire oh yeah oh dear yeah here
you look like a crazy prospect that
didn't go quite the way I wanted it I
was an innocent bystander
yeah well I gotta tell you the game of
thrones people are going to look
fabulous I think we're looking forward
to eat it backfire that was the most
amazing let you down follow followed by
daddy
good news Wall Street house looks like
Andy it looks like you've been doing
filthy things at the circus I'm excited
for the glitter tater ship of season
seven here you're never gonna get that
out oh that's you now that thing that is
you now next question Christmas huh I
want to crap uh I want to welcome Josh
McDermitt this is his first San Diego
comic-con yeah how you doing I'm doing
good this is fun have you seen have you
seen the Eugene cosplayers have you seen
some Eugene cosplayers I've seen a lot
of Eugene cosplays I feel like you know
guys dress up as Eugene that's to be
expected I get it maybe you don't have
the body to be daryl that's fine ah but
I'm starting to see a lot of female
Eugene's awesome because I think they
have the long hair so they can kind of
put it into a mullet easily and that
sort of thing but I look at them and
it's like I don't want to sleep with
Eugene like I don't know you know it's
I've never really pictured Eugene as a
sex symbol so if if I don't get killed
off Scott Campbell I would love to
explore that storyline it's what you
know the thing is like they the
attention has to go to the details right
they have to I'm seeing cosplay for
Eugene where they've set up a bookshelf
like from episode 5 a season 5 where you
mean was spying on Rosita and Abraham
having sexy time yeah and they'll walk
around with like a makeshift bookshelf
that they're just creepy
it's like that's genius I love you
that's awesome uh Michael Cudlitz it
that's sort of weird they sat you in
between your ex-girlfriend and your
current girlfriend that's a very strange
dynamics kind of awesome he planned it
that way and the man you want to be with
what what was that like what was that
experience for him what was this
epiphany that he had in the last you
know last season well I think it's
win-win
aha Jerry Jerry Jerry no I think that
look early on I think that both both
Abraham and Rosita found each other and
it became a relationship of convenience
if you follow the graphic novel Rosita
used her looks to get to kind of to
survive early on my win her way the way
and after she met Abraham Abraham was
the only person that she had met that
didn't want anything from her physically
that actually did connect with her as a
human and he taught her how to be a
soldier which he excelled at so I think
that for the two of them it just made
sense at the time now that I think
Abraham sees a tomorrow and a tomorrow
after tomorrow he can't deny what his
heart is failing so it's not convenience
anymore it's it's actual practicality
and he finds a lot of things that he
just admires in Sasha to be those things
that he has always held important in his
life that she already possesses will to
survive strength intelligence beauty and
he wants to share that were there any
and as hard as it is because I think he
still loves Rosita would do anything for
Rosita
and/or Eugene because they are they're
his family there comes a point where you
can't deny what you're feeling
and this is a time in the story where
he's allowed to feel and he's reminded
that there are things that are worth not
only dying for but living for and finds
that in her oh that was masterful I
don't know how you pulled that off
because I think there are a lot of women
the honest like you son of a bit and now
everyone's crying Sumiko what was it
like working so closely with Cudlitz
this past season oh it was it was so
much fun um he and I have a lot of fun
together a lot of jokes a lot of it was
a lot of good times and we broke down a
few barriers too because we spent a lot
of time in that car and um you know it
got all the way it got real you know he
had to help me with my breast milk a
couple times um you know I was still
nursing so I'm pumping every couple
hours but we cooped up in this car and
and he's like no no give it give it to
me I got it I got it
I'll take it to the cashier I'll take it
I'll take it I got it I got it I know
what this is about I got it I got you
know that the coffee is that the oh geez
and so you know it was it was such a it
was such a great connection you know so
he's such a gentleman and he was so it
was very brotherly and sisterly he was
you know taking taking great care and um
I'd go well yeah he's a dad and I take
it take it yeah thank you in the cooler
yeah thank you so so that was cool
um but yeah a lot of good conversation a
lot of good times we I learned a lot too
because you know obviously this man he's
been at it for a long time a lot to
learn from him so it was great this is
also Christian Serratos his first time
at San Diego comic-con what nervous this
is so intimidating there's so many of
you know it's Michael Michael helped her
with her breast milk it's not
intimidating because these people waited
like they're here to see you like they
wanted there it's not it's not like
they're holding their arms like you
better win us over like their I want to
be charming and you want to be
and I happen to think I'm very funny so
I'm a nerve to give me pity laughs if
I'm not what what's been rewarding touch
me miss Jen Chris Jen listen Josh really
jealous right now
what's been rewarding for you for Rosita
zark so much um first of all just
getting to work with all these people
coming in you know after the show has
been established and and and coming in
when I did was a little nerve-wracking
you want to make sure that you do a good
job and and you hear so many great
things about the show and you just want
to like perform and you want to bond and
and I had heard so many great things
about the cast and their work ethic and
and I was just really excited that they
all took me in and I was able to learn
so much from everybody I mean even just
in the last episode of season six I feel
like you know we're all such good
friends and we all trust each other so
much but to be able to go through that
last episode with everyone was such an
incredible bonding experience I really
feel like I I grew as an actor that's
going to be a pivotal moment for me for
a long long time and that doesn't happen
when you can't trust the people you're
with it just cannot so so is really
exciting for me to be here for however
long I'm here and just know that I've
had this moment and even things like
Josh was talking about like cosplay that
is so exciting for me I mean I'm just
like everybody else I get excited about
TV shows and and cool fun interesting
things so to see people dress up as a
character I'm portraying is such like a
nerdy exciting thing for me I love it so
much even when it's a guy even when it's
a guy even when Michael does it I get so
excited the closer a little tight but
there's there's there's a few like
latina comic-book characters that are
written but not many that have been you
know put on a big screen or small screen
so it's just really exciting for me that
I see so many Latinas come up to me and
say how excited they are to have a
really strong woman that they could
dress up as so that makes me really
proud and I hope that I you know get to
keep portraying this really strong woman
for for as long as I
can uh thank that was very well done
Christian Serratos uh the Ross Marquand
if you don't know is an amazing
impressionist and we've tried to get can
you just quickly just I know you could
use do Harrison Ford for like a quick
second just you know what Chris I'm
tired of your cook your horse crap
always getting me up here doing the
Harrison Ford and all this I'm over it
all right get off of my panel what else
does that happen on the satellite are
you able to do that on this Idol what's
a good are you able to do that on the
set allowed or is it really serious
intense it sometimes we're just doesn't
make sense to be jokey obviously but I
remember last season in 612 we were
doing that the raid on the compound and
Cudlitz and Seth Gillian thought people
don't notice but Cutlass does an amazing
Sylvester Stallone and Seth Gilliam does
an amazing Robert DeNiro and I was
playing Mick I was murderous Meredith
from rocky and I was like come on you
you gotta get in there you gotta give
these shaders hell well we go get in
there you know they're trying to take
half our stuff you're not gonna let them
do that oh yeah well we just didn't have
the stuff and we can walk away well
you're done rocks in your head come on I
don't know but you do exciting work done
I don't think they're gonna kill all of
us and they killed me well they're gonna
kill some of us and it could be you
babies will be human
come on thought of trying no if you
don't shut up I'm gonna kill you all
right sorry
you